a lot of times when you look at really
good companies you publish the work in
really good high impact places like
science or nature the Sloan fellows
experience is like joining a new family
it's full of respect and love and
friendships at a depth that you may not
otherwise get outside of your own family
what is bonding immediately is the
immense feeling you have for
intellectual discussions for sharing
experiences
I could not have made it through the
summertime without my study group and my
learning group and quite frankly The
Experience would not have been the same
had it not been for the larger community
it is phenomenal the rate at which you
go from being intimidated by these
strangers to being dependent upon these
friends
and then you start helping each other
and then it's that unsolicited person
that reaches out and helps you something
that you didn't think was grandiose it
was simple for you somebody else
appreciates
important pendings one of our phrases is
no fellow Left Behind the goal though
for me was to make our work get out and
help people something that MIT Sloan has
is is the Greater Community that is MIT
one of the great technology universities
in the world one of my friends is a
professor in chemistry at MIT said Bob
why don't we start a company and my
first four employees were actually
former students who had worked on this
project in the lab here you have an hour
with Bob Langer one of the best known
scientists in the world
it's quite an extraordinary thing to be
on a campus where that's happening all
around you every day
what our class decided to do was to
organize some sessions and it's a
20-minute amount of time that you have
as a fellow to tell the rest of the
class whatever you want to tell them all
the values that that I have they come
from my family and I hope Bruno and
myself will be able to give the same
sense of groundness and the same sense
of dignity and life enjoyment as my
parents and my brothers gave to me this
became this nice
carried on we'll stay in touch with you
and we will definitely keep you in our
hearts thank you very much
over the course of a few months we
realize we've pretty much challenged one
another and tested one another and
gotten to know one another in enough
ways that we've developed a trusting and
mutually trusting Community
you have this support of knowing the
people who are going through the same
transition that you are going through
you have friends that are going to have
your back Wherever You Are
and go for it